hey Jake what's up John Luke what is
your favorite part about Mass Effect the
characters I love the characters what do
you say we killed them all and that's
exactly what we're gonna do this is the
first episode of the saddest party on
the Citadel a show where we're going to
try to kill all the characters in Mass
Effect that we can in the most sadistic
way possible this is just the worst
thing ever it's it's awful it is
terrible but anyway this is episode 1
let's get this show on the road shall we
[Music]
so the goal is is to get to the very end
of the Citadel DLC where you throw a
little party but we want no one there
with us except the ones that you can't
kill which i think is james Liara ET and
joker yes oh and then a couple like
steve is there and the yeah but no one
gives a about Steve now you may notice
we're playing Mass Effect 2 not Mass
Effect 1 that's because not much happens
in Mass Effect 1 we're kind of gonna be
skipping around a bit here yeah we want
to like show character deaths but anyway
to like add insult to injury we're gonna
give ourselves points when we can some
fun yeah yeah we are so we're chasing
high scores - speaking of killing people
we did not kill Rex yeah so we didn't
kill Rex and then we also chose to let
Ashley yes I because because this
portrait is terrible this portrait is
awful and if you want to watch Kate and
die because no one likes Caden but
anyway we planned this out alright so we
spent about two hours trying to figure
out a way to kill everyone we have a
I'll put the picture up we wrote on a
board for like two hours yeah we looked
like Psychopaths people kept stopping by
at one point another group needed to use
the meeting room they were like oh that
looks interesting we're like yeah don't
ask don't ask don't know but yeah so
we're gonna start basically right before
the suicide mission with the if' beacon
i believe and then we think we've come
up with a way to set up our team so
everyone will die well not everyone will
die but the people we want to die during
this suicide mission will hopefully die
there's a couple gamble parts which i
think is gonna make it fun we're not
sure yeah try to calculate the best we
can I have a newfound respect for that
suicide like I already thought it was
really cool but seeing how meticulous
and like hidden tricking yeah yeah
there's all these hidden stats in it
like you it it's way easier to keep
everyone alive that's actually not that
hard to do in Mass Effect well you have
to
why you have to spend two hours in a
meeting room writing on a whiteboard to
figure this out yeah you know like when
in those movies the Psychopaths always
have like all these like photos and
stuff and there's all these like strings
that go from one that's how I felt talk
about the mouth with you all day okay
starting off we're gonna kill the whole
crew of the Normandy at least emotion we
don't get points for this though no cuz
this isn't our fault maybe bonus points
for Presley yeah we should get back five
points all right Markham yep there's one
oh we romance Liara oh that's yeah
that's another thing we were mentally
our oh yeah oh yeah she can't die so
whatever we'll just break her heart if
we do manage to kill her it's 10,000
points though that's what I put in the
document oh I mean technically you by
the way you could bet we're picking all
renegade options all the time yeah this
is I call him sadistic Shepard although
right now his name is John Shepard
except whoever created this when an end
deleted bah yeah it shoutout to we had
to use the Mass Effect character creator
say Mass Effect saves calm in order to
create this so shout out to the person
who created this safe for us I still
think it's weird you went in there and
deleted the H stone John I that is
because the standard is John like it's
John right away but then you went in and
delete the pH you may be wondering by
the way why we picked male Shepard when
female Shepard is superior and that is
because she is so superior that there's
no way she could be this incompetently
bad and get all her so odd killed so we
had the big man Shepard don't be stupid
stupid look Joker you can't die we gotta
get you out of here
wait a minute do we get points for
killing Shepard in this because Shepard
dies here I think it's brought back to
life brought back to life although I
feel like if Shepard dies in the suicide
mission that should be yeah but a lot of
points but we can't continue if that's
the case we originally were thinking
about doing a run that just does that
which is just kill everybody but it's
not fun enough yeah because a lot of
people die off screen in Mass Effect 2
like for instance if you don't have a
high enough defense for the distraction
team then they die and it's just kind of
off-screen I believe yeah
and there you have it that's the end of
our series I hope you guys enjoy I'm
just gonna huh everyone's dead
let's call it a day god this scene is
still so good yeah oh all my favorite
openings period oh my god
the sound - oh what a way to go oh yeah
that music
all right market down Jake one death
hundred points oh yeah you've never seen
this what why didn't we have a save why
do we need to do this
it plays it anyway it just doesn't make
you pick the choices that is a dumb at
why is he diagonal what's he doing why
is he this is like you may be wondering
how I found myself in this situation
can we skip this no god this is terrible
like why is there just gonna fill in
this is gonna it's gonna fill in it's
like an interactive they don't like it
seems like they got lazy oh do you know
what an [ __ ]
either way she'll let you no matter what
it should let you skip it yeah or it
should just give you like you could say
hey just give me the list here maybe I
can oh my oh my god oh I'm gonna rabbit
at it oh my gosh and stuff like there's
60 Shepherds talking oh [ __ ] there was
an actual choice oh oh no all right oh
no no no look at this beautiful face
we're gonna not pick this custom
appearance oh yeah we could create Obama
have you seen that the the face code
somebody created like a perfect Obama
really it's so good I'm gonna put it up
oh yeah but what are the stuff in the
thing where stuff goes in oh yes far
apart we're really close good I feel
like when they're far apart though he's
got a blind spot right in front of him
and it is in that blind spot where all
his that one the so fetch is bad he
looks like he's from like an early 2000s
like kind of [ __ ] ripoff grunge band are
we feeling good about this I don't know
if I'd call it good but I'm feeling
something suppose you want to play at
home there's your there's the code oh
boy I look at that face and I just think
Ruth
he's gonna get some people killed yeah
the last face they'll see when they die
oh boy and look at that we're already on
the ship we got a lovely outfit for our
Shepherd look at that it's got some
facial scars some things happened yeah
you skipped ahead we skipped ahead four
hours we're at the end of the game but
we've ignored by the way you can do the
majority of Mass Effect 2 in 4 hours we
have but also sadistic Shepard here he
doesn't he doesn't want to do loyalty
missions but we're gonna do a couple
we're gonna do a couple very specific
loyalty missions so that characters will
not die so that they can then die later
when we want them to exactly that's how
we roll we have every character here
except for Legion which we're gonna get
but we're not gonna turn on we're not
we're not gonna get them yet we have to
wait for some stuff to happen so right
now we're gonna do someone's loyalty
mission for the ants so the end of the
first episode we're gonna we're gonna do
a mission here you keep you keep rubbing
your hands like this it's making me
nervous yeah I feel like you're up to
something you know I just figure it's we
got some time before we have to go get
Legion so we'll do someone's lousy
mission you know ok no we're not cuz I'm
out of fuel well I I kind of like Sayid
I was gonna say he was sort of the Rex
replacement like the grizzled war vet he
had a lot of fun stories yeah he
definitely felt kind of like he felt
like he was just kind of like stuck in
there though like he didn't really seem
to fit the rest of the team that much I
but he's really well-written yeah his
voice actor is fantastic yes I eat
always felt like a cut character you
know yeah like they put him back in but
like clearly he meant to he was meant to
be more fleshed out
shot in the back and left it's gonna be
you soon
dark foreshadowing in order to get to
this point I had to just like rapid tap
through all the dialog so I'm like
feeling that itch just skip everything
oh my god
sadistic Shepard looks scary he looks
way worse in the than in the character
creator like a look at that oh yeah
profile oh my god you've been looking at
his dumb face for the last four hours
him in who's uglier him reside
[Music]
definitely him Rob yeah we don't need to
know about your backstory it doesn't it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter you're
gonna die soon you notice his hey I
don't know if this is the game if it's
our character creator did it or just the
game is that way his hair is really look
on the back oh yeah it looks like it cut
too early yeah it's a bad haircut it's a
really bad haircut
you just signed your death warrant Sonny
you're on fire
whoa yeah on fire hey are you talking
don't you have to do something good for
him to die though
yeah so you actually have to pick the
good option
we have to go Paragon in order to do our
ultimate renegade action also it looks
like this guy's a vacuum on his back all
of them civilian well this is like a
refinery outfit but all of the all the
outfits on the NPC's look terrible in
this it's like just certain angles
they're just really bad I mean that's
not the focus of this video but uh I
just can't forget loyalty we save them
we're here to free these people we're
going in I'm here to save you everyone
oh god no let us burn just the guy just
jumps off the rafters and dies well wait
what you put it away what did I not have
you know what I don't actually need this
I'll just shoot you with my fire bullets
there we go yeah I totally denied him oh
okay that makes sense
drop the thing on it drop the thing on
it drop the thing on it oh it wasn't
even near it oh dude if I play stop why
does this have helped it's metal it
should just have armor and a shield good
point
Oh blind-fire
you Blackfyre this game no baby I don't
know blurry no no you're screwed
what happened none of this is going in
yeah
what oh Jesus oh boy
[Music]
if I'd fight him from here vitam I can't
wait I can't I can't I have a bug report
Bioware hey Bioware patch your game
patches 7 year old game wait 7 yeah 7
year old game oh my god
7 years wait ok I'm trying to do it yeah
yeah I hope you just stuck again oh I
could I can only play the game by
bouncing the people I think he needs an
actual named other than statistics
Shepard or John Shepard yeah not sure
what it'll be
actually I noticed gonna be Nicolas Cage
Shepard well yeah Nicolas Cage Shepard
that's it
this is bad yeah you're kind of in a
corner oh boy
well at least these rounds work well on
the armor and he's not moving oh you
know what he got stuck in the same spot
yeah yeah dumbass who would do that
who would ever get stuck over there not
Nicolas Cage Shepard oh yeah mmm
you keep rubbing your hands damn nervous
it's making me nervous I'm excited
you've never seen this I have for us but
you've never seen you've seen him how
you kill him I think when I first played
it maybe no maybe I haven't yep that's
gonna work
he actually shoots the guy next to him
though I like that it's a nice time oh
look at that cheekbone
you just cost me 20 years well there's
your thumbnail I mean you deserve that
startup this fires I eat it makes sense
that you'll burn in it yeah screw you
what makes you think I'm gonna do that I
kind of like I don't want you on my [ __ ]
more oh no the shadow was on his face
and not working correctly light doesn't
know what to do with him what wait I
can't wait what what why can't I know
wait what no there should be an option
to kill him what what this ruins
everything
oh my god go look it up what did we do
Oh No suicide mission
Oh weave through it after the suicide
mission I didn't know that [ __ ] okay so
we jumped the gun on that one Jake yes
we did I think we might have to reload
the save which is what we're doing now
actually and we're gonna advanced a
little bit in this story and see if we
can put this mess back together yeah we
need to we need to get rid of somebody
can we opt not to keep someone I think I
have just the solution geez I can't
believe it which part that we planned
that whole damn thing out and it turns
out you can't die unless yeah it doesn't
mess up our grand plan it shouldn't it
just moves that part of the grand plan
and around a bit yeah
what about the job Joker will tip over
shop Joker
jarring yeah the prerendered cousin yeah
I know those enjoying switch so guys I
just could have done without that this
is cool though that's rad god I actually
remember hating this mission like
playing it because it's all husky it's a
lot of Hustons Saiyans not the cars
bunch of Priuses a bunch of sounds and
Priuses husks are the flood of mass
effect enemies yeah no thank you
well I remember they were you could
fight like them in the beginning of one
and that was it even fight off the rest
of the game yeah a couple times but
pretty minor yeah and in this oh three
they're like a main enemy yeah they made
them a little bit better to fight in
three though they like reworked them Oh
grunt don't know well he's got to die
eventually
alright good point make it happen right
now running off to the side cool I was
just talking about Eden Prime
nobody touch anything
how about we all take a step back from
the weird alien Impaler devices I was
just shut up tally shut up Charlie
five days clearly Shepard wasn't in
control of this station I was a little
bummed
how late Legion shows up yeah especially
since you don't seem that much in three
I feel like or at least not enough he's
one of those characters that I really
wanted to get more time with yeah I wish
she did more cool things with the hole
in his chest like kept his guns there I
don't know or something yeah wow man
that thing is inaccurate it's terrible I
actually picked up the assault rifle
training so I can use this that gun
that's the mattock right yeah the guns
rad it was a DLC in this one and then
they just at I yeah there were a lot of
DLC weapons and two they just like gave
you in three yeah I like this is like my
favorite gun a multiplayer two for three
Emma
oh my gosh do you have a shockwave or
whatever yeah yeah there we go
forgot about that one yeah that's a good
one that clears them out I realize this
is a very eclectic episode just really
bouncing around all over this game yeah
most episodes won't be like that now
especially especially once we get to
three where I mean just the nature of -
it's a lot of like singular missions
three all the stuff we need to focus on
is in kind of in each arc of the main
story yeah so probably in episode we'll
have an episode be per arc watch out
it's the wimpiest looking jab ever just
oh definitely an improvement in three
yeah we get that we'll get the biotic
punch yeah it's good the Sprint and
ground pound punch oh boy I definitely
got sick of this by the end of a run
yeah I pardon me was like man I missed
that like in three they took it out and
I'm playing it again I'm like next you
know what and take it back maybe just
not as often Wow these missions are
actually pretty short yeah I kind of
forgot about how short they are
especially if you skip a lot of the
dialogue and don't really bother
exploring
he gets knocked out does it can I guess
get knocked out huh
that's like does that make a sense I
don't think so
just so you to back off maybe she said
Shepherd back off okay it was like
shooting her what are you doing oh no
I'm talking to her oh okay yeah she's
not doing anything oh she's just sent
her in a little drown do all the dirty
work you know what I can't wait till you
die Liara
Liara Talley strike it from the records
cut it
Oh Talley Oh No use your thingy boom oh
that's satisfied weird Sally go
oh he's laying on the ground don't sleep
I've never heard that line before should
we take it in to the shipper just leave
it here I think no matter what he takes
it takes it right yeah that's true but
I'm not sure it's worth the risk
Shepherd there's no time to debate in
town come on
Talley help me bring this thing on the
ship so I can immediately get rid of it
what if it just missed
we're gonna I didn't he was gonna make
it I know I was really worried Oh
another day for now we've stored it in
EDSA I caught all right here it is to
fight the reapers an intact gift would
be invaluable to Cerberus system so this
is sort of what we agreed on that
out of all the things that could happen
a legion she's not even turning him on
felt like the most insulting yeah he's
one of my favorite characters and oh I
love though yeah we're not gonna
tournament just yeah Cerberus get some
right
Cerberus got somewhere we don't turn him
on which one which one oh I don't know
I've let's just send him the Cerberus so
we can see cuz I've never seen this
conversation before sure Jacob it's
because of eating prime that I'm giving
to get to Cerberus Miranda is right we
need better weapons I have to look at
the big pig and that bigger picture is
killing my whole squad Jacob I have
other goals in mind don't you worry
about them do you think Shepard has that
same board that we have in his office I
hope so somebody walks in a Shepherd I
want to talk to bet what's uh what you
got going over there nothing about it
don't worry about it you should go
well we didn't kill someone but we kind
of did yeah Legion is just gone yeah how
many points is that I don't know this
was the way I didn't check before we did
this but anyway 775 775 market
[Music]
well I think that is the end of episode
1 the next episode we'll get into the
suicide missions will finally start
killing some of these teammates left and
right you're not gonna want to miss it
and if you like this make sure to
subscribe we'll be having lots of Mass
Effect Andromeda stuff coming soon so if
what we're doing is heinous and terrible
well subscribe anyway and you can check
out some Andromeda stuff soon until next
time why are we so close to her face
he's just just creeping on her she's
looking like what are you doing
Shepherd please stop also I can't work
like the outfit that you gave him
because only of course I'd pick that one
there's no other choice what he's gonna
wear the normal ship uniform no way no
when this is an option it's so dumb bye
everybody
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]